ganz deutschland steht auf der kippe zum
zweiten corona lockdown ein land in
unsicherheit in ungewissheit ein land in
dem die korona infektionszahlen
drastisch steigen in dem die korona
strategie der politik fast täglich
mittlerweile angepasst wird
ein land in dem die korona proteste
deutlich zunehmen wieder auf den straßen
wie hier heute in berlin teilweise
gewaltbereit in der nacht gab es bereits
ein brandanschlag auf das robert koch
institut und ein land in dem der
bundesgesundheitsminister selbst
inzwischen an corona erkrankt ist nur
noch von zu hause regiert und das tut er
heute mit diesem flammenden appell an
die deutschen
es ist ernst und hören sie nicht auf
diejenigen die verharmlosen und
beschwichtigen wir brauchen jetzt ein
kraftakt ist die korona lage in
deutschland mittlerweile außer kontrolle
dass diskutieren wir jetzt hier live bei
bild guten abend zum bild politik talk
wir stellen die richtigen fragen heute
an hamburgs ersten bürgermeister peter
tschentscher bei dem die korona
infektionszahlen in der stadt auch
kräftig steigen heute 168 neuinfektionen
und der trotzdem zu kämpfen hat in
seiner stadt auch mit illegalen partys
sowie hier gestern abend zum beispiel in
hamburg altona als dann die beamten doch
relativ hart eingegriffen haben außerdem
bei uns im studio markus blume csu
generalsekretär
die
die grünen fraktionschefin katrin göring
eckardt sozusagen zugeschaltet aus dem
homeoffice bei uns und ebenfalls
zugeschaltet sie sitzt in bayern sabine
leutheuser-schnarrenberger die frühere
bundesjustizministerin von der fdp in
allen schönen guten abend und eine
muntere spannende diskussion peter
tschentscher würden sie noch guten
herzens guten gewissens sagen sie haben
in der hansestadt die korona lage voll
ins im griff na ja wir sind in einer
angespannten lage werde schon in einer
millionenmetropole alles im griff
aber wir versuchen unsere strategie die
sehr erfolgreich war bisher fortzuführen
wir kontrollieren wie sie sagen
die sie gezeigt haben natürlich auch
dort wo sich die wenigen bürgerinnen und
bürger die das noch nicht einsehen
verantwortungslos verhalten aber eine
große im griff werden sie heute auch
nicht mehr sagen dass das kann man im
moment nicht sagen angesichts daher
keine regierung der welt kann 80
millionen menschen einfach im griff
haben also wir haben klare regeln in
deutschland
wir sind darauf angewiesen dass alle
beziehen und ich glaube alle regierungen
der bund die länder regierung versuchen
wirklich in einer gemeinsamen strategie
jetzt diese hohen infektionszahlen
wieder zurückzuführen sie einzudämmen
und zu diskutieren wir noch später
weiter der blume in bayern da steigen
die zahlen noch drastischer als bayern
tschentscher in hamburg würden sie sagen
dort die lage außer kontrolle
mittlerweile das stimmt tatsächlich gar
nicht also bayern liegt im moment beim
infektionsgeschehen in deutschland nur
im mittelfeld
aber insgesamt muss man sagen ist die
lage in deutschland in allen ländern
dramatisch wir haben ein extrem
dynamischen infektionsgeschehen wir
sehen dass sich infektionszahlen wieder
verdoppeln und das nicht im monat oder
in mehreren wochen sondern alle paar
tage und deswegen kann man fast sagen
ganz deutschland wird langsam zum
hotspot und deswegen ist es auch
notwendig dass wir uns natürlich die
strategie anschauen wie wir es schaffen
denn auch hier die kontrolle zu behalten
und aus einzelnen gesundheitsämtern wir
schon heute in deutschland dass sie dort
tatsächlich an die grenzen massiven
sagen sie haben es im moment noch unter
kontrolle in bayern also unter kontrolle
und im griff ist ein großes wort in
diesen zeiten wir tun jedenfalls alles
um jede einzelne infektion
nachzuvollziehen das ist für uns im
moment nach wie vor das maß aller dinge
blum hat kann die gesundheitsämter
angesprochene moment ist es so wenn es
eine infektionsfall gibt dann muss man
bei jedem 1
müssen die gesundheitsämter
nachverfolgen mit wem diese person
kontakt hatte also müssen fleißig
herumtelefonieren bei wie viel prozent
der infektionsfälle schaffen ihre
gesundheitsämter in hamburg das noch
erreichen gar nicht mehr alle sind
einfach sehr viele
das ist der unterschied vielleicht auch
zu früheren zeiten wir haben einen
infektionsfall und dann sehr sehr viele
kontakte weil gerade die jüngeren
menschen einfach ja ihre freizeit leben
doch sehr intensiven genießen in diesen
tagen und das passt einfach nicht zu
dieser situation deswegen mussten wir
jetzt auch weitere kontakt beschränkung
beschließen es ist jetzt so dass wir
egal ob privat im öffentlichen raum
es dürfen nur noch zwei personen aus
zwei haushalten aufeinandertreffen weil
wir nur ganz kurz entschuldigung bei
denen bei den gesundheitsämtern bleiben
sie sagen das werden immer mehr die man
danach verfolgen muss das heißt wie viel
prozent von denen schaffen sie noch die
nachverfolgung zu gewährleisten
also wir sind noch hinter jeder
nachverfolgen man erreicht eben auch
nicht sofort alle wenn die telefonnummer
nicht stimmen wenn wir das einfach zu
viele sind einen infekt fällt die zahl
der infektionen steigt und die zahl der
kontakte die wir pro infektionsfall
nachverfolgen steigt auch noch weil wir
einfach doch zu viele kontakte noch im
öffentlichen raum im privaten rahmen
haben als mannschaft das doch eigentlich
gar nicht mehr berlin hat das ziel
längst aufgegeben würden sie sagen herr
blume
das können wir gar nicht mehr leisten
wir können gar nicht mehr jeden
einzelnen fall nachverfolgen
deswegen gibt es ja zuschaltung von
personal für die gesundheitsämter
beispielsweise von der bundeswehr dafür
sind wir sehr dankbar und wird noch mal
zu unterstreichen was der tschentscher
gerade gesagt hat in der ersten welle
hatten wir bei pro infizierten 34
kontakte zum nachverfolgen und jetzt
haben die gesundheitsämter pro
infizierten zwischen 50 und 80 kontakte
nach zur verfolgung das zeigt einfach
warum beispielsweise die bundeskanzlerin
so recht hat wenn sie sagt wir müssen
unsere kontakte beschränken
das ist nicht mehr ganz so als ich das
im moment noch bei 100 prozent oder ist
das ein ziel was längst nicht mehr
erreicht werden was unrealistisch
geworden ist das ziel ist nicht
aufgegeben haben wie herr john charles
habt man kommt natürlich an die grenzen
des systems und wenn sie sich jetzt ein
gesundheitsamt anschauen und sie haben
30 fälle 30 mal 80 das sind sie gleich
einen ganz großen grössenordnungen die
müssen alle erreicht werden und das
alles in möglichst kurzer zeit
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir
wirklich eindämmen und ist nicht einfach
laufen lassen kann göring eckardt ich
habe gerade schon gesagt in berlin hat
man dieses ziel
die längst aufgegeben erscheint ihnen
das so ehrbar und sinnvoll das ziel ist
aber eins was was überhaupt noch zu
erreichen ist oder was längst
unrealistisch geworden ist diese ganzen
kontakte nach zu verfolgen
es gibt ja viele untersuchungen die
sagen da muss jetzt erst mal nach
befolgen als dass wir jeden einzelnen
jeder einzelnen in berlin hat man sich
jetzt entschieden zu sagen
die menschen würden bitte diejenigen
anrufen die sie getroffen haben dazu
gehören voraussetzungen denn erstens
gehört dazu
das transparent ist wie was entschieden
wird zweitens gehört dazu dass wir
einheitlichkeit haben und dass dieses
tempo drauf und dass dieses hin und her
endlich aufhört dass alle wissen woran
sie sich halten müssen und eigentlich
haben wir ja nett das ist eigentlich
ziemlich coole erfindung gewesen dass es
diese app gibt aber sie schafften bei
weitem nicht ihre möglichkeiten aus das
ist natürlich könnte man darin längst
kontakt tagebuch natürlich selber
früheren aus datenschutz und könnte man
auch sehr genau nachvollziehen wann hat
man getroffen viele menschen wissen das
ja gar nicht mehr
juni kommt es jetzt so vor als ob die
alle überrascht sind davon dass wir
jetzt und mehr menschen drin sind wo es
draußen kälter wird eine höhere
infektionszahlen haben und ich glaube
das hätte man voraussehen wann genau so
wie man hätte voraussehen können ist die
schule wieder anbringt im september oder
weshalb es fehlen sind und leute weg
leutheusser schnarrenberg jetzt fragen
wir hier in der runde nach kann man das
überhaupt noch schaffen können die
gesundheitsämter dieses ziel der
nachverfolgung in jedem einzelnen fall
überhaupt noch gewährleisten berlin hat
sie wenigstens ehrlich gemacht so bitter
das ist aber die sagen halt schaffen wir
nicht mehr lassen wir dann auch bleiben
solche fälle zeigen die nicht selbst
wenn der blume und tschentscher noch
sagen wir versuchen das zumindest aber
dass die strategie einfach nicht
funktioniert bisher
wir haben ja jetzt gehört von der
verantwortlichen für alle ärzte in den
gesundheitsämtern dass die situation
wirklich kritisch in einigen und zwar in
nicht wenigen gesundheitsämtern ist man
weiß gar nicht wie viel beschäftigte
insgesamt dort sind viele warten noch
auf die unterstützung von
bundeswehrsoldaten manche
gesundheitsämter sagen wir können
eigentlich nur 30 40 prozent
nachverfolgen also ich bin überhaupt
nicht für alarmismus ganz im gegenteil
aber ich glaube nüchtern betrachtet ist
das nur ganz begrenzt umsetzbar und da
wo wir dieses ganze dynamischen
infektionsgeschehen haben auch gerade in
großstädten aber wir werden es ja auch
noch höheren von berchtesgaden da
gelingt das in meinen augen nicht und
deshalb ist ja die überlegung angestellt
worden soll es solche cluster kontakt
tagebücher geben soll überhaupt mehr in
clustern gedacht werden was könnte man
da erleichtern mit blick auf die
gesundheitsämter aber nüchterne blick
zeigt das doch in weiten teilen der
große überförderung da ist und die
ankündigung viel personal hinzuschicken
eben nur ganz langsam schrittweise
durchgeführt wird und die digitale
situation in den gesundheitsämtern auch
noch nicht auf der höhe der zeit ist der
blume in münchen steht die ampel schon
auf dunkelrot mittlerweile anfangs ging
es nur bis rot jetzt geht's bis
dunkelrot und münchen steht schon genau
da was kommt nach dunkelrot wie viele
farben oder rottöne brauchen sie noch
ich denke politik da vor allem eines
nicht aufgeben und ab einem gewissen
punkt sagen wir lassen es jetzt einfach
laufen das wäre aus meiner sicht der
falsche weg sondern man muss sich dann
auch wieder zusammensetzen überlegen an
welchen stellen müssen wir nachjustieren
ich kann mich erinnern herr tschentscher
bei der letzten mpk der konferenz der
ministerpräsidenten hat man gesagt wir
wissen nicht genau ob die maßnahmen
ausreichen wir schauen uns das mal an
wenn ein kunde ist das alles auf
wiedervorlage bist in dem moment auf
bewährung mit dem was wir tun und ich
kann auch die appelle dies in diesen
tagen gaben nur noch mal unterstreichen
eigenverantwortung in dieser phase ist
durch nichts zu ersetzen der starke
staat versucht sein bestes aber es ist
auch wichtig dass jeder einzelne sieht
welche verantwortung er hier hat
kontakte zu reduzieren und es den
behörden im grunde nicht unmöglich
machen diese pandemien griff zu bekommen
es gibt ja verschiedene szenarien mit
denen man dann immer rechnet ganz
schlimme szenarien weniger schlimm was
sind die zahlen mit denen sie hat
changer für hamburg rechnen bis
weihnachten also so weit würde ich jetzt
keine prognose wagen aber wir haben
jetzt vor geraumer zeit schon
unmittelbar nach der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz noch bevor
wir diese 50er grenze nach lkw
überschritten haben gesagt wir machen
die sperrstunde ab 23 uhr weil wir
wissen das ist etwas was voraussichtlich
sehr sehr die kontakte einschränkt dann
auch gerade in den späten stunden wo
viel alkohol konsumiert wird wo die
distanzlosigkeit dazu nimmt wir haben
jetzt noch mal diese kontakt beschränken
auf zwei haushalte daneben gelegt und
wir hoffen dass es eine wirkung hat und
werden dass die nächste zeit sehen
ich finde es auch ein bisschen
eigenwillig dass jetzt plötzlich alle
sagen da hat ja alles keinen zweck mehr
jede person die sie erreichen ist ein
gewinnen weil diese personen dann weiß
sie muss sich testen lassen und man hat
ein stück ein risiko verringert wichtig
ist auch dass wir noch mal versuchen in
die vergangenheit zurück zu verfolgen
nicht nur die die die kontakt
nachverfolgung auch die rückverfolgung
ist entscheidend um zu erkennen wo haben
wir cluster wo haben wir wirklich die
infektionsursache und wir haben die
gesundheitsämter vom frühjahr an
konsequent jetzt stärker ausgestattet
wie sie jetzt bei 350 personen die
vollzeit in der kontakt nach verfolgung
tätig sind wir bekommen die vision
unterstützung der bundeswehr
ich würde jetzt dieses ziel nicht
aufgeben auch wenn sie nicht in der
realität immer alles schaffen das ist
auch vom ersten tag nie der fall gewesen
weil es einfach aus sorglosigkeit gibt
im umgang mit dem konto
akt listen wo dann der druck eingetragen
so dass wir bis heute aber das ist nicht
genau sie haben wenngleich einen grafen
mit der regeln wir haben nicht nur ein
problem das der strategie wir haben auch
ein problem der disziplin müssen
wirklich alle bürgerinnen und bürger
davon überzeugen das ist jetzt wirklich
drauf angesagt die kanzlerin heute in
der verschlossenen tür ja da habe sagt
disziplin distanzieren und da haben sie
recht
leutheusser schnarrenberger helfen wir
sprechen darüber dass strategien die als
strategien verkauft werden
möglicherweise ganz schnell wieder
überholt sind vergangene woche
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz beschließt
man die ampel nur sieben tage später ist
eigentlich klar diese grenzwerte an
denen man sich orientieren konnte die
sind so niedrig mittlerweile die sind
schon wieder überholt man muss nach
steuern kann man von der politik in so
einer phase wirklich nicht erwarten dass
es eine strategie gibt die länger als
eine woche hält kann man mehr klarheit
eben doch erwarten mehr strategie
ich glaube schon dass es notwendig ist
in einigen punkten den strategiewechsel
einzuleiten und ein strategiewechsel ist
aus meiner sicht dass man die grundlagen
für das handeln des staates im
infektionsschutzgesetz mal sehr viel
konkreter fast dass dort auch die
maßnahmen beschrieben sind die dann
ergriffen werden können unter bestimmten
voraussetzungen dann ist das für den
bürger klarsichtige einsichtiger wir
haben sperrstunde in haben durch um 23
uhr jetzt dem münchen um 21 uhr
man darf nicht weiß nicht wo man
interessen das ist genau das stichwort
und sollten sie das dann hier noch
einmal das wort fall frau leutheusser
schnarrenbergers genau das stichwort
diese verschiedenen sperrstunden ich
will ihnen da ein beispiel zeigen dass
ganz nahe zumindest in deutschland ist
und dass diese ja teilweise ihren corona
grenzen ganz besonders gut zeigt ein
beispiel bei den nachbarn aus österreich
da steht mein kollege karl keil im
moment auf dem katschberg in luftiger
höhe und erkläre uns mal karl schönen
guten abend was das findet ihre chor
ohne grenze da bei dir ist
okay wir arbeiten haben schon und
arbeiten an dieser irren corona grenze
die karl kam uns da gerade vorstellen
durch katschberg zwischen salzburg und
kärnten auf der einen seite die sperren
stunde ab 22 uhr auf der anderen seite
eben noch nicht und karl übernimmt noch
einmal ja du hast jetzt ton und erklär
uns was da in dieser werk hätte mich
hörte mich ja wohl hörte mich jetzt
jetzt hierzu die patienten genau wir
sind ja ein familien berg in katschberg
1850 metern höhe
das liegt jetzt hier in salzburg die
sogenannte ganz konkret um schließlich
gehört erst mal meinen posten
das jetzt erstmal alles gehört und jetzt
gibt natürlich diese ihre regel in
salzburger land da gilt es nämlich und
das ist nämlich die regel gibt das hier
um 22 uhr sperrstunde ist aber wir
stehen jetzt einfach mal alle auf ja man
kann es jetzt hier natürlich sehen man
kann es nämlich sehen denn durch diese
wirtschaft verläuft die landesgrenze
nach kärnten und in kärnten ist die
sperrstunde um 1 uhr das heißt man muss
jetzt einfach nur den tisch wechseln und
kann drei stunden länger trinken und
dazu jetzt bei mir auch der gegner ganz
kugel hütte
das ist der peter peter kannst du uns
mal sagen wie kommt diese ihre grenze zu
stande
wir haben sehr viel glück kommt
eigentlich also ergänzen sind nicht die
man es negativ sie ist wirklich so schön
dass wir kärnten salzburg und
durch die grenze ist einfach das
positive passiert aber spielt das jetzt
irgendwie wie kann man das erklären also
die behörden müssen irgendwie sagen also
verbreitet sich das virus auf der seite
des tisches anders als auf der seite das
scheint ja nicht möglich zu sein
na ja da wäre es schön zu wissen wenn
man dann da ist oder nicht da ist und
schlussendlich ist es so dass wir sehr
glücklich sind dass wir dort wirklich
einen grenzfall grenzfall haben der was
sehr positiv ist wo gesungen wir dürfen
da an da sein und das ist das hänge
davon auch arbeitsplätze ab wo wir sehr
stark nach vorne gehen wo wir unsere
mitarbeiter beschäftigen dürfen
und das ist ganz ganz wichtig auch und
wie ist das jetzt was bedeutet für dich
wie viele tische musst du denn zu machen
oder wie viel da musst du dein sperren
wie was bedeutet das finanzielle ist ja
wirklich sehr schwierig weil das ist
dass es ist uns nicht gut weil wir
werden alle ingo eingebremst und das tut
unseren kollegen in salzburg nicht gut
wir können nicht alle wegsperren wird
die auch noch der ganz stark nach vorne
gehen auch in kärnten haben wie das
grüne noch gott sei dank
und das ist ganz wichtig wir dürfen
positiv nach vorne gehen nicht immer uns
alle verstecken sondern dass wir dürfen
das leben auch wir dürfen mit corona
leben das wird es hat vor wahrscheinlich
andere sachen gegeben gibt es jetzt auch
wieder und das ist wo es sei es gibt
kein zurück
es geht nach vorn und nicht zurück genau
mit diesen worten geben wir einfach
zurück nach berlin
also das ist hier wohl ja die erste
grenze die man da finden kann aber in
dem fall verbindet eine grenze auch und
genau mit diesen worten zurück in die
hauptstadt
danke kahl und größe dort nach
österreich zu unseren nachbarn also dort
die korona sperrstunden grenze die
verläuft mitten durch diese berghütte
wir müssen aber gar nicht so weit gucken
es gibt ganz ähnliche beispiele an
unserer deutschen grenze zum beispiel an
der deutsch holländischen grenze
victory hat aus der not eine kreative
corona idee entwickelt denn sein
fischrestaurant steht mitten auf der
deutschen der lettischen grenze und
genau das wird für ihn während der
pandemie zum vorteil in den niederlanden
ist die gastronomie für mindestens vier
wochen wegen der hohen infektionszahlen
beschlossen deshalb ist nur noch außer
haus verkauf möglich während in
deutschland der verzehren restaurants
gestattet ist
deshalb bietet die rag seine ware zum
mitnehmen an für gäste die vor ort essen
möchten hat er draußen auf der deutschen
seite ein bewirtungszelt aufgestellt die
grenze läuft genau hier im laden hin
dafür habe ich
das gebet vorne ist wie den deutschen
grund gebiet sie können hier noch nie
störend ist nur noch für take away was
sie können draußen ist ein deutschen
grund gebiet da kannst du deine erste
noch aufpassen aber schönes verwandte
straße gemacht für die leute wie tauchen
auf essen würden die können das draußen
auf ist und jetzt nochmal zum nachmessen
die theke befindet die holländischen
gebiet hinter der hauswand nur zwei
meter entfernt beginnt deutschland dort
steht das zelt die tische haben den in
deutschland geltenden abstand von ein
meter fünfzig und alle bedingungen
tragen masken ohne diese idee hätte rick
seinen laden womöglich schließen müssen
oder der sand sagen wir davor wird ganz
schwierig ja weil ich hab jetzt ungefähr
50% verletzten und wenn ich da dezenten
ich habe dann ich denke mal 75 zurück
geht es nun wieder zurück an die theke
fisch verkaufen
ob und wie lange er das noch kann hängt
von den chor ohne entwicklungen in
deutschland und die niederlande ab ja
also ein weiteres beispiel für
einigermaßen irre corona grenzen im
moment die der alltags- und mit sich
bringt die regeln mit sich bringt frau
göring-eckardt können sie über solche ja
extrem beispiel bei können sie über
solche lachen oder längst nicht mehr
naja ich finde zum namen nicht mehr um
europäische grenzen und innerhalb
europas marktes noch angehen dass die
länder sich noch nicht so schöne einigen
können
es wäre natürlich wichtig dass wir
innerhalb deutschlands klarheit haben
und dass die kanzlerin das heft des
handelns viel stärker in die hand
bekommt muss man sagen nicht nimmt weil
ich glaube das hat sie haben versucht es
kommt darauf an dass die parlamente
entscheiden dass der deutsche bundestag
dann ist klar sagt was gemacht wird in
welchem fall ich glaube das hat auch
damit zu tun dass wir mehr transparenz
und mehr akzeptanz dadurch bekommen dass
die parlamente nicht nur mitreden
sondern auch tatsächlich mit entscheiden
und wir wissen ja mehr als wir anfang
des jahres als wir im märz im april im
mai gewusst haben über dieses virus
deswegen denke ich die einheitlichkeit
auf der einen seite klare regeln was
nicht geht aber eben auch kranken regeln
wie etwas
ich glaube das ist auch ein ganz
wichtiger punkt dass die leute das
gefühl haben müssen ja das kann ich
unter diesen bedingungen machen und das
kann ich eben auf gar keinen fall
einheitlichkeit innerhalb deutschlands
der blume könnten sie ihren bürgern in
berchtesgaden erklären warum die nun
seit vergangenem dienstag im lockdown
leben müssen und neukölln hier in berlin
bei fast denselben werten mittlerweile
aber eigentlich ganz normalen alltag
weiter macht haben nicht nur die shisha
bars geöffnet sondern ab morgen nach den
herbstferien auch die schulen wieder
sie will zunächst sagen dass ich kein
verständnis dafür habe dass man regeln
lächerlich macht denn dahinter steht ja
was wir im moment haben das bemühen der
politik dass wir anders als in der
ersten welle versuchen so viel freiheit
wie möglich zu schützen
damals musste man schnell handeln und
deswegen hat man alles herunter gefahren
aber jetzt versuchen wir ja regional
auch angepasste lösungen zu finden wir
versuchen die schulen offen zu halten
die kita ist offen zu halten die
wirtschaft am laufen zu halten und
versuchen auch gerechtigkeit im kleinen
herzustellen und da mag es immer wieder
grenzfälle geben und das große
missverständnis ist man kann regeln
vielleicht noch irgendwie versuchen zu
umgehen wie wir das auch in den
beiträgen ist gesehen haben aber das
corona kann man virus kann man nicht
umgehen
und deswegen kann ich nur noch mal sagen
der bürger muss sich nicht an die regeln
halten der politik verstanden ja dass
neukölln beispiel ist er aber schon
extrem ist also sie haben in
berchtesgaden den lockdown wieder auch
wenn er nicht ganz so heißt gemacht dort
sind die schulen geschlossen worden
familien mussten ad hoc wieder ihren
alltag genauso umstellen wie sie das im
frühjahr mussten in neukölln halten ich
fast dieselben werte
das leben geht fast normal weiter hier
auf der straße und wie gesagt die
schulen haben morgen nach den
herbstferien wieder ganz normal geöffnet
es passiert nichts also die einfache der
einfachere weg auch in berchtesgaden
wäre vielleicht gewesen gar nichts zu
machen aber dann machst du dich
natürlich schuldig weil du dafür sorgt
dass ein solcher regionaler hotspot da
nicht begrenzt bleibt sondern
diffundieren kann und wir wollen
jedenfalls dort in berchtesgaden zeigen
mit diesen einschränkungen in dieser
zeit dass wir versuchen dort die lage
wieder in den griff zu bekommen
und ich sehe da bei allen diskussionen
diesem einzelfall natürlich gibt da
schon ein grundverständnis dafür nochmal
die weiße fahne zu hissen bei der korona
bekämpfung ist das grund verkehrte weil
wir einen gang ans lang erleben wie der
weise dass sie zahlen explodieren
und dann haben wir in wenigen wochen
verhältnisse wie in frankreich in
spanien oder in vechta sie müssen doch
ihren bürgern in berchtesgaden nicht nur
erklären warum sie es geschlossen haben
sozusagen dort wieder warum sie
runtergefahren haben sondern die werden
ja fragen näher und warum dürfen die da
in neukölln einfach so weitermachen
das abgeben auf diese frage es ist viel
schwieriger ein bezirk einen kleinen
bezirks einer millionenmetropole
gesondert zu behandeln als einen kreis
der eine gewisse abgeschlossen hat hat
wo man sagen kann
hier kann ich maßnahmen ergreifen die
nicht dadurch wirkungslos werden dass
durch einen bezirk jeden tag von allen
anderen bezirken leute unterwegs sind
das heißt sie haben unterschiedliche
situationen in deutschland und das ist
auch der wesentliche grund weswegen die
länder das sind ja nicht die
regierungschefs allein ist sind die
menschen in den bundesländern die sagen
warum soll ich hier in mecklenburg
vorpommern warum soll ich nicht
einkaufen gehen wenn bei uns keine
infektion sei ist ja aber um das ding
lautet die frage angehörigen erkannt mal
wie sie sich das vorstellt dass über 600
bundestagsabgeordnete jetzt für ganz
deutschland festlegen was in
berchtesgaden passiert was im bezirk
neukölln passiert und was im bezirk
harburg in hamburg passiert das möchte
ich erleben wie wie plausibel dass am
ende sich auswirkt und wie viel proteste
ist dann gibt wenn leute sagen und ich
glaube sie wollte überhaupt mal gefragt
werden im parlament ja das muss man ja
zu ende denken wie das dann praktisch
gehen soll wir sind ja unter zeitdruck
wir können ja nicht sagen wir
debattieren jetzt zweimal das heißt es
geht nur autoritär
es geht ihr unterricht auf der auf der
grundlage des infektionsschutzgesetzes
dass der bundestag beschlossen haben sie
kurz hinter sich schauen beide schütteln
vehement den kopf frau leutheuser das
geht nur so wir müssen so schnell machen
das ist nur ohne parlament das geht
nicht ohne parlament aber es geht nicht
dass wir diese einzelentscheidung jetzt
plötzlich zentralisieren das ist all das
will auch keiner jeder
einzelentscheidung zentralisieren
aber das parlament ist kein schlaf laden
die können so schnell gesetze
verabschieden wir haben das erlebt in
der euro-krise wir haben sie jetzt auch
schon erlebt also im parlament quasi
also bürokratie anhängsel zu verstehen
dass man gar nicht fragen darf halte ich
für falsch es ist ja auch nicht gesagt
dass dann jede entscheidung das
parlament trifft aber dass das
infektionsschutzgesetz derartig weit und
unbestimmt ist gerade diese allgemeine
norm das ist ja dieser paragraph 28 das
ist ja unstreitig und deshalb kommt
sogar nachdem die opposition auch die
fdp im landtag in bayern es eingebracht
hatte jetzt von der csu auch der antrag
in den bundesrat und die aufforderung an
die bundesregierung endlich diese
regelungen konkreter zu fassen wo
natürlich immer dann am ende bei der
kommune auch im rahmen eines spielraums
dann entschieden wird aber das war
einmal klare rahmen haben auch über die
maßnahmen einen klareren rahmen schaffen
weil im moment da war die erfahrung noch
nicht da das eben noch nicht so im
gesetz steht und das geht zügig außerdem
hätte man schon die ganzen letzten
wochen ja dass auch vorbereiten können
und jetzt kommt man wo die ferien zu
ende sind aber besser jetzt und dann
auch im parlament debattieren und dann
die bürger mitnehmen
ich glaube das ist ein deutlich besserer
weg weil einfach viele bürger jetzt auch
schon ein bisschen unsicher sind sie
blicken nicht durch sie empfinden das
teilweise bisher als ein fleckerlteppich
und es geht doch darum das sagen wir
doch alle
wir müssen die bürger mitnehmen ohne die
bürger mit den bußgeldern mit zum
polizei nutzen regelungen leider nicht
viel er oder gar nichts sie sagen es vor
leuten die bürger blicken nicht durch
klingt fast wie ein vorwurf ist gar
nicht von ihnen so gemeint aber ich
würde sagen bei dem wust an
formulierungen und verordnung ist es
fast unmöglich mittlerweile
durchzublicken frau göring-eckardt sie
waren direkt angesprochen von
tschentscher wie stellen sie sich denn
genau vor sehr sagt sinngemäß das muss
in teilen autoritär moment laufen das
ist nicht machbar es muss dir zentral
auch geguckt werden angemessene nationen
sind ja auch eigentlich dann guckt
werden musste diese tools und was man
dann genau tut aber dass wir gemeinsam
rahmen haben wenn die herren letzte
woche eine situation erlebt wo die
bundeskanzlerin aus der besprechung
ministerpräsidentin rausgegangen ist
gesagt hat das reicht ihr nicht und
eigentlich mehr und drei tage später ist
es beherbergt ist verboten dass einige
länder verhängt haben durch die richtige
stoff worden da minimiert
das vertrauen bei den bürgerinnen und
bürgern wenn sie sich daran halten
sollen
ich hab ihn dass man die massen trägt
dass man weiß was man wann tut dann
müssen sie wissen was wann wo geht
übrigens glaubt das wäre auch eine gute
aufgabe für die app dass man das weiß
hier ist ein risikogebiet das muss ich
jetzt machen ich will ich will euch als
garten entscheiden aber ich möchte gerne
dass wir einen rahmen setzen dass der
bundeseinheitlich gilt dass wir wieder
ein großes vertrauen haben dass zum
beispiel klar ist natürlich werden die
schulen als letztes zugemacht
wir haben doch gelernt dass das volk um
absurd ist übrigens auch in der abwägung
natürlich steht weihnachten vor der tür
sie haben vorhin gesagt darüber wollen
sie sich nachdenken
das verstehe ich bin weil wir ja im
moment angucken was passiert in den
nächsten tagen was schon genug ist dass
wir nicht gut vorbereitet sind aber dann
haben sich ganz viele menschen in
unserem land ins gedanken wird der
weihnachtsgottesdienst stattfinden unter
welchen bedingungen kann ich meine
familie besuchen und da kommt ein
zweiter ganz zentraler punkt wir müssen
doch heute jetzt dafür sorgen dass die
menschen in den altenheimen die menschen
die in pflegeheimen diejenigen die
alleine sind
in der zeit ist sowieso die dunkle
jahreszeit es nicht alleine bleiben und
dafür muss man voraussetzungen schaffen
dass sollte man gemeinsam tun von den
schnelltest angefangen die zur verfügung
stehen müssen über die frage unter
welchen bedingungen kann vielleicht
sogar eine veranstaltung stattfinden
vielleicht ein adventskonzert was auch
immer das muss einheitlich geregelt
damit sich alle daran halten damit nicht
die 130 gemeinden damit nicht diejenigen
die daran ende der stange sind alle
entscheidungen treffen müssen das auf
ihren schultern haben das können die
kaum noch ertragen leutheusser
schnarrenberger sie kennen die politik
so lange ist das vielleicht auch gerade
bisschen ja selbst gewollt und relativ
bequem in der zeit halt durch zu
regieren und nicht jedes mal die
parlamente zu fragen ich war schon etwas
entsetzt als ich aus der landtagsdebatte
hier in bayern gehört habe
zum diskutieren brauche das parlament
nicht wenn man nicht gerade was
entscheiden oder wenn da gesagt wurde
wir brauchen nicht noch
organ wie das parlament wir haben schon
genug behörden mit denen wir zu tun
haben also vielleicht ist es ja angenehm
und ich glaube es ist in manchen
situation gerade auch bei gefahr im
verzuge natürlich notwendig dass
regierungen zügig konsequent kompetent
handeln
aber das darf nicht zur gewohnheit
werden wir dürfen nicht diesen jetzt
deutlich gestärkten staat als das modell
nehmen so nach dem motto hat wunderbar
geklappt das machen wir jetzt mal doch
ein bisschen stärker und wir gewöhnen
uns dran dann bekommen wir eine
situation wo es für unsere demokratie
ein bisschen gefährlich werden können
würden sie so weit gehen zu sagen in
bayern der würden sie so weit gehen frau
leutheuser zusagen in bayern der herr
söder hat das relativ autoritär bisher
gelöst
also ich glaube dir gefällt sich darin
da aufzutreten er ist da ja auch sehr
gut in der lage das drum aufzutreten
aber ich glaube so ein bisschen das
durchregieren klar das gefällt ihm schon
sehr herr blume jetzt haben wir
verschiedene beispiele gehört einerseits
der wust an unterschiedlichen regelungen
tschentscher erklärt dass gut und sagt
na ja wir müssen uns natürlich dezentral
machen weil es in der stadt ganz anders
aussieht als in flächenländern
trotzdem lässt es dem bürger oft ratlos
zurück und teilweise wütend zurück wir
haben heute proteste gesehen wieder
teilweise gewaltbereit auf der straße in
berlin
welche rolle spielt dabei das fehlen
oder erkennbare fehlen einer strategie
dass die leute ja nicht nur hilflos sind
sondern auch zunehmend so ist unser
eindruck wütend sind zornig sind also
zunächst mal es gibt ja eine strategie
die strategie in deutschland ist ganz
klar wir wollen diese pandemie eindämmen
und wir wollen dabei nach möglichkeit
auch den erfolgskurs des ersten
halbjahres fortsetzen keine strategie
dass er ziel
es gibt ein hotspot strategie der
ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundesregierung die miteinander
vereinbart ist die darauf gerichtet ist
dass sich regional hotspots
identifiziere dann dort die kontakt
nachverfolgung mache und das ganze
eindämmen
und dazu kommt natürlich vieles andere
wir können jetzt eine parlamentarismus
debatte führen ich glaube aber dass es
im wesentlichen eigentlich
eine scheindebatte ist natürlich kann
man und das ist glaube ich schon ein
wichtiger punkt wenn die pandemie jetzt
erkennen wir uns noch länger sehr viel
stärker beschäftigen wird also nicht nur
kleiner ausschnitt wie ihn früher
sondern erkennbar länger die gesetzliche
grundlage machen aber es ist doch
irrsinn zu glauben dass ich jede
einzelne maßnahme die ich in drei
monaten vielleicht mal brauchen die
heute noch gar nicht zu denken ist dass
ich die irgendein gesetz jetzt schon
rein schreibe ich glaube ist der falsche
blickwinkel ich habe ehrlich gesagt
nicht verstanden weil frau
leutheuser-schnarrenberger gerade ihren
blick auf den bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten gerichtet hat warum
die fdp kritik so harsch ausgefallen ist
eine ansprache der kanzlerin
ich finde in einer freiheitlichen
gesellschaft ist der appell an die
bürger eigenverantwortlich zu leben
eigentlich etwas zutiefst liberales und
warum man dieses instrument nicht als
erstmal etwas nimmt und sagt jawohl wir
versuchen es damit bevor wir über andere
dinge reden warum da so harsche kritik
aus der fdp kommt habe ich bis zum
heutigen tag ehrlich gesagt nicht
verstanden
die die kritik könnte darauf zählen dass
die maßnahmen eben als unklar empfunden
werden und auch einfach teilweise nicht
verhältnismäßig
das führt doch das wird doch im moment
zu dem verhalten derjenigen die eine
analyse was ist denn nun klar wenn man
sagt reisen auf das notwendigste
beschränken und persönliche kontakte auf
das notwendigste beschränken
unklar ist dabei schwindler unklar ist
zum beispiel warum man nur köln was
völlig anderes gilt als b in
berchtesgaden sie haben das begründet
nur trotzdem das müssen den leuten in
berchtesgaden erzählen die werden sich
noch den kopf greifen weil warum die
kinder dort in berchtesgaden nur wieder
wieder aus der schule ist eine frage der
politischen wirklichkeit anderswo in
berlin hat man am dritten oktober noch
ein tag der clubkultur aufgerufen
als man anderswo in deutschland schon
gesagt hat partys clubs usw
wir müssen runter fahren aber all das
führt doch zu einem verhalten dass ganz
viele sagen also ich halte mich nur noch
an die regeln die ich auch für sinnvoll
halte also ich glaube nicht dass wir
jetzt noch wir sind noch nicht an den
kern des problems glaube ich in unserer
haltung sei als erster die
landesregierung an denen die fdp und die
grünen beteiligt sind verhalten sich gar
nicht anders als alle anderen
landesregierungen alle versuchen jetzt
in dieser situation etwas zu machen was
sie in ihrem land erklären können und es
gibt eine strategie die sagt die
maßnahmen die jetzt erforderlich sind
die müssen wir auch sofort ergreifen
aber eben auch nur die wenn wir darüber
hinaus gehen
wenn wir dinge tun die vielleicht jetzt
nötig sind aber vor zwei monaten noch
nicht dann dürfen wir sie auch gar nicht
machen wollen wir fangen gerichten
kontrolliert wenn es gibt immer wieder
entscheidungen auch von gerichten
gigahertz mäßigkeit ja wo
verhältnismäßigkeit und
gleichbehandlungsgrundsatz geprüfte herr
burges und deswegen ist das alles nicht
so leicht und wir fahren die strategie
wirklich ist die maßnahmen zu treffen
die für die phase der pandemie
erforderlich sind und das möglichst zu
koordinieren zwischen den ländern und
auch da wo es geht werden die parlamente
eingezogen
der bundestag hat im rahmen dieser
kampagne ganze reihe an gesetzesvorhaben
mit beschlossen mit dem mehrheiten die
die regierung stützen sowie das er
demokratie der fall ist auch wir in den
ländern machen dass wir beteiligen wir
berichten fortlaufend beachten auch
beschlüsse der parlamente wenn es wenn
es dort etwas gibt aber wir können jetzt
nicht so tun als wenn das alles nur an
ein problem der politik organisation ist
dass bestimmte menschen das sind ja gar
nicht so viele
dem ist das eigentlich egal woher die
regeln kommen
sie lehnen sie ab und das ist kein
missverständnis dass man in hamburg
derzeit keine partys feiern kann und
trotzdem gibt es gastronomen die mit 90
leuten im keller sich mitten in der
nacht um 1 uhr solche partys
organisieren
das hat keinen das ist keine frage von
kommt das aus dem bundestag aus einer
landesregierung oder irgendwo her
sondern es gibt einfach ein paar
menschen die haben noch nicht verstanden
dass es wirklich auf das verhalten aller
ankommt weil wir uns nicht gegenseitig
ansehen in der tat werden solche bilder
am wochenende noch mehr lebe ja in
berlin da gab es ein fetisch party mit
600 leuten die die polizei da gestern
aufweisen fragen sie mal warum sie für
die männer des soll sagt einfach keine
lust hat relativ wenig verständnis für
diese menschen glaube ich in der breiten
bevölkerung sehr sehr viel unverständnis
trotzdem es gibt ein breites verständnis
dafür dass die regeln verhältnismäßig
sein sollten und ich glaube frau
leutheusser schnarrenberger ihre ihre
ihr verständnis ist davon auch dass man
das eine oder andere kritisieren dürfte
und dass wenn man kritik übt dass man da
nicht sofort ebendieser fetisch
fraktionen oder der alu gut fraktion
angehört sondern dass man eben schon
fragen darf man ja könnt ihr bitte eine
strategie entwickeln könnt ihr bitte
verhältnismäßige regeln aufstellen und
regeln die vielleicht ein bisschen
länger als sieben tage halten
das ist das selbstverständliche in einer
demokratie dass ich ja auch die aufgabe
der opposition und gerade die fdp ist
nicht corona leugner und hat mit denen
die jetzt sagen ist mir alles ganz egal
was da passiert cola ist für mich nichts
anderes als eine grippe also jetzt
feiern wir mal ordentlich das ist nicht
unsere position weil das
unverantwortlich und zu lasten der
mehrheit der menschen geht aber dass man
hinterfragt reicht allein der blick auf
die infektionszahlen aus muss man nicht
stärker in den blick nehmen wie viele
sind krank wie ist das gesundheitssystem
wie liegen wie ist das mit den
intensivbetten dass man das in maßnahmen
mit einbezieht dass man aber auch
wirklich bei sperrstunden sich fragt wie
in berchtesgaden ist jetzt wahr
da war also natürlich eine starke
sperrstunde lockdown ist ja dort
durchgeführt worden
aber essen zum mitnehmen war dann auf 20
uhr ist geklagt worden
jetzt kann man auch nach 20 uhr das
machen also das sind alles dinge wo der
bürger sagt mich dann macht es doch
gleich verhältnismäßig also geeignet
notwendig erforderlich aber so dass es
in dem rahmen ist wohl nicht am ende die
gerichte dann immer wieder korrigieren
sie haben es oft gemacht der rechtsstaat
funktioniert also aber das ist nicht das
was unbedingt eine breitenwirkung hat
die vertrauen ihn jetzt exekutive
verstärkt frau geärgert doch einmal also
unverhältnismäßige regeln oder regeln
die als solche wahrgenommen werden
regeln die uneinheitlich sind gibt es da
eine gewisse verantwortung eben doch der
regierenden für eine zunehmende
ablehnung oder für so eine
geisteshaltung von wegen da kommt ich
halte mich halt nur noch an das was ich
für sinnvoll halten
es müsse erst noch mal sagen vor der
camp gibt ja eine große mehrheit von
menschen in unserem land die regeln
akzeptieren und die sie einhalten und
die das sehr ordentlich machen das auch
wollen und ich glaube das vertrauen der
wahl sollten wir nicht riskieren und ich
finde das was jan tschentscher rat wenn
leute in keller party feiern dann ist es
etwas wohl natürlich die
sicherheitsorgane eingreifen müssen und
das auch tun sollten das gilt auch mit
demonstrationen in berlin ich war sehr
schockiert dass wir heute demonstration
hatten in berlin und ganz kleine nicht
eingeschlossen worden ist und wo man
sich natürlich das sind wirklich relativ
erschreckende bilder heute gesehen
gewesen dort am alexanderplatz zunächst
später auch in anderen teilen der stadt
durch ein riesiges richtiges problem
also erst natürlich für die
polizistinnen und polizisten die da im
einsatz waren die natürlich gefährdet
sind auch übrigens ansteckungsgefahr
wenn man sich sowas anschaut immer wir
ja in den letzten tagen auch gehört dass
ein haupt ansteckungsfälle der
familiären zusammen das familiäre
zusammentreffen die familien freiheit
der besuch bei den eltern bei den
angehörigen bei freundinnen und freunden
und da man sich das anschaut dann muss
man einfach zur kenntnis nehmen
offensichtlich ist noch nicht ganz klar
was eigentlich los ist wie groß die
gefahr ist und deswegen plädiere ich so
sehr dafür dass wir diskutieren dass wir
transparenz sind dass wir gemeinsame
rahmen haben nur darum geht es ja die
dann unterschiedlich angewandt werden so
dass ich nicht ganz rund darauf
verlassen kann dass ist und es gibt noch
etwas was ich jedenfalls fühle wenn ich
mit vielen menschen unterwegs rede die
sagen mensch wir müssen uns doch jetzt
aber auch sagen nach dem gewicht wie es
geht nachdem wir wissen hier ist geht
das denn wirklich ist wenn man die
künstlerinnen und künstler die kultur
schafften die solo selbstständigen die
selbständigen anguckt die kleine lernten
haben die sich wirklich um gegebene
konzept bemüht haben in den letzten
monaten und jetzt große angst dass
wieder das untergraben wirklich
stattfindet das ist etwas was mich
jedenfalls sehr beschäftigt den muss man
sagen also wollte entweder es kann
stattfinden ideen und konzepte so topp
sind oder ihr habt eben eine absicherung
damit wir nicht so die gigantische
unsicherheit weil der euro hat sich so
eine gigantische unsicherheit bei
menschen bei denen es wirklich um die
existenz geht und in altenheime was ist
mit den gottesdiensten die kultur die
solo selbstständigen sind alles gruppen
die die heute so sehr im blick haben
müssen wir besser wissen was geht und
denen wir sagen müssen ja das mit ihm
zusammen halten das meinen wir übrigens
immer noch und egal was wir machen wir
haben euch einen blick und irgendwie
immer existenz ich will ihn noch eines
zeigen hersteller ganz kurz weil das
jetzt kein totales randphänomen mehr ist
wie man
ja behandelt wird in berlin
beispielsweise wenn man eben dann maske
trägt in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
zum beispiel da sind heute morgen wie
diese eine familie die dort in der
berliner s-bahn steht doch gern mit
maske und ein mob sozusagen der immer
wieder ruft maske ab maske ab um die
videos werden dann im internet gepostet
stolz gepostet tschentscher wie würden
sie sich in so einem moment
und weil sie mit ihrer familie oder mit
freunden verhalten in der s bahn
also das ist sehr ungewöhnlich also so
etwas habe ich in hamburg nicht gehört
im gegenteil ich habe eher das problem
dass manchmal verkäuferinnen sagen ich
muss jetzt auch noch unsere kunden
darauf hinweisen dass sie eine maske
tragen sollen
ich bin eigentlich ganz froh wenn es
eine klare regel gibt und dann auch
jemand hilft und ich nehme er war das
eine große mehrheit versteht dass wir
wirklich in einer sondersituation sind
in der man diese doch sehr sehr ja
lästigen vorkehrungen treffen muss und
so etwas ist glaube ich nicht der regel
die regel dass er dass sich diejenigen
die sich sorgen machen
darüber ärgern dass ist einige gibt es
sind ja nicht viele die so tun als wenn
man das auf die leichte schulter nehmen
kann und das ist glaube ich ein problem
man kann nicht immer nur mit bösen
worten und mit polizei gegen so etwas
wir müssen auch viel erklären gute
kommunikation machen und auch glaube ich
rüberbringen dass wir diese zeit bis es
eine impfung gibt am besten dann
überstehen wenn wir jetzt die richtigen
kontakt beschränkung auch wirklich
durchhalten
das macht es uns allen also sowohl den
jungen die gerne unterwegs sind als auch
die älteren die er wirklich in ihrer
gesundheit in ihrem leben gefährdet sind
ein gemeinsam leichter und deswegen sind
jetzt auch wo die neuen möglichkeiten da
sind durch die schnelltests die ersten
schritte sind jetzt dass wir zum
beispiel weil das frau geringer kg mann
gesprochen hat dass wir auch darauf
achten dass nicht wieder fliege und und
seniorenheime in sozialer isolation
kommen wir machen jetzt test konzepte
damit dort der infektions eintrag durch
besucher kontrolliert wird so dass
weiterhin besucher stattfinden können
aber eben dennoch diese ausbrüche nicht
stattfinden müssen
das heißt wir wir sind schon überall
dort wo es möglichkeiten gibt dort sehr
in den in den entscheidungen und auch in
den vorkehrungen und das kommt uns dann
zugute
und wir reden darüber inwieweit ist
unterstützung geben gibt in der breiten
bevölkerung angesichts der
verhältnismäßigkeit oder eben fehlende
verhältnismäßigkeit solcher regeln
wollen die runde für kurz einmal
erweitern um professor bernd
raffelhüschen der uns zugeschaltet ist
von der uni freiburg und der hat eine
ökonomische rechnung gemacht er hat das
also das ganze die korona krise nicht
medizinisch betrachtet sondern einmal
ökonomisch und hat sozusagen einmal
ausgerechnet wieviel lebensjahre wir
ökonomisch oder statistisch durch diesen
lockdown im frühjahr geschützt haben und
wie viele lebensjahre wir dadurch aber
auch verloren haben und was ist ihr
ergebnis und wie kommen sie zu so einer
rechnung cara viele müssten guten abend
guten abend erst einmal und die rechnung
ist im prinzip nichts anderes als zu
sagen wir machen jetzt mal ein
statistisches auge also wir reden jetzt
nicht mehr über irgendwelche
durchgeknallten da in berlin
die auf der straße da sitzen und wir
reden aber auch nicht über die
hysteriker und mir scheint in dieser
sendung auch viel ahnung und hysterie
unterwegs zu sein und das ist der
statistik eben halt nicht er ist
derjenige das mit mit sagen wir mal
neutral aber auch durchschnittlichen
also eher mathematischen auge sieht und
da muss man ganz klar sehen der erste
locker und in dem früher gemacht haben
und den wir natürlich weltweit überall
gemacht haben jetzt wir reden nicht über
irgendwie bayern wäre so schleswig
holstein ist sondern weltweit
wir haben weltweit im grunde genommen
die gesamte weltwirtschaft lahmgelegt
wir haben einen wachstumseinbruch
bekommen und offensichtlich wird die
zweite welle uns diesen
wachstumseinbruch noch weiter bescheren
so was wir getan haben ist wir haben im
grunde genommen wenn wir mal und jetzt
gehts nicht um infektionen infektionen
interessieren uns nicht von uns
interessieren schwere fälle todesfälle
alles andere ist nicht wirklich relevant
und die schweren fälle und die
todesfälle waren wirklich beschränkt auf
die doch etwas ältere bevölkerung also
im wohnen wirklich jenseits der 75 jahre
im wesentlichen einig vor erkrankt und
da haben wir durch den lockdown im
prinzip ein schwedisches szenario
vermieden
ein schwedisches niveau hätte uns
wahrscheinlich circa 25 bis 30.000 mehr
menschenleben gekostet wobei menschen
leben kann man nicht rechnen sondern man
errechnet in der statistik inhalt
verlorene lebensjahre
der mensch ist nicht etwa ich kann kein
menschenleben retten auch wenn die
politik das immer wieder sagt das geht
gar nicht
ich kann nur das leben verlängern oder
verkürzen so was wir gemacht haben ist
wir haben für eine bestimmte gruppe von
menschen das leben verlängert wenn wir
da rechne dass wir schwedisch gefahren
werden werden wir wahrscheinlich bei
circa 25 bis 30.000 mehr toten gewesen
diese toten haben aber eine ferne
lebenserwartung gehabt nach
statistischen jahrbuch nur das ist das
was uns hier interessiert in der
statistik alle ferne lebenserwartung
gehabt wahrscheinlich von drei jahren
das heißt auf gut deutsch wenn wir wenn
wir rechnen dann habe im grunde genommen
irgendwo zwischen 100 und vielleicht
300.000 lebensjahre durch den lockdown
der uns natürlich aufgezogen worden ist
wir konnten ja gar nicht anders
insofern gibt es da keine diskussionen
aber ca diese menge an lebensjahren
letztlich verloren die frage ist
natürlich jetzt was kostet uns der
lockdown der lock down und den der
einbruch des wirtschaftswachstums der
wird unsere sagen wir mal technischen
fortschritts raten doch deutlich drücken
in der welt und zwar jetzt nicht wieder
bayern oder berlin sondern weltweit
und wenn weltweit das wachstum zum
einbruch oder nicht zum einbruch aber
deutlich weniger stark steigt als es
sonst gestiegen wäre
dann verlieren wir ja auch
lebenserwartung wenn nur reiche
gesellschaften leben länger arme leben
eben nicht länger sondern wir brauchen
reales wirtschaftswachstum ist erklären
raffelhüschen einmal kurz diese rechnung
von ihnen wie gesagt natürlich eine
statistische rechnung können wir einmal
kurz zur diskussion stellen herr
tschentscher wie finden sie solche
rechnungen dass man einmal kosten und
nutzen gegeneinander liegen sehr
theoretisch ich verstehe ihren ansatz
aber es fällt mir schwer lebensdauern
gegeneinander aufzurechnen
das ist in dieser in dieser rein
statistischen betrachtung ein effekt
nicht berücksichtigt es gibt nicht nur
um tote durch corona es geht darum dass
sie unser gesundheitswesen wenn es ein
überlastet wäre so wie es ja in vielen
ländern sehen
dann geht es nicht nur um die behandlung
von krone erkranken dann geht es auch um
ganz reguläre andere herzinfarkte
schlaganfälle unfallopfer die nicht mehr
intensiv medizinisch betreut werden
können weil unsere krankenhäuser
überlastet werden
diese situation haben ja gerade in
italien zu diesen schrecklichen bildern
geführt und wer sich dort mal informiert
wie das dann wirklich stattgefunden hat
in den krankenhäusern dann versteht man
dass das keine rechnung ist die
irgendwie statistischen das ist eine
ganz ganz schlimme situation wenn ein
gesundheitssystem nicht mehr in der lage
ist schwer kranken menschen die hilfe zu
geben die man ihnen geben müsste frau
göring-eckardt ist so eine rechnung ja
ökonomisch total wichtig war eine
zeitlang vielleicht nur der virologe
jetzt mit am tisch saß aber der ökonom
eben fehlte oder finden sie so was
moralisch verwerflich
nein das wird er nicht um moral aber das
was wir tatsächlich brauchen ist dass
die verschiedenen professionen
miteinander darüber reden was eigentlich
gerade passieren und welche maßnahmen
sinnvoll sind und deswegen haben wir
auch gesagt man braucht eigentlich genau
so einen jungen auf der gerne auf der
bundesebene weil in den ländern gibt es
ja zum teil schon aber das ist dann
wieder nicht vergleichbar
man braucht eigentlich so was gehen kann
dem iran wo die verschiedenen
professionen auch miteinander
diskutieren was bedeutet jetzt
eigentlich was wovon ich nichts zu sehen
halte ich nehme an das hat herr
abmischen in seiner rechnung so
angewandt ist so zu tun ist und er noch
da weitermachen können wo wir vorher
aufgehört haben das wären wir noch eine
andere logik diese die wird es nicht
wundern dass ich das anspringen die
klimakrise ist auch noch da und die geht
auch nicht weg und die müssen wir
bewältigen und wenn man sich dann
anschauen wie viele menschen leben
das kostet wenn wir bei zwei grad oder
mehr landen würden dann haben wir ein
riesiges weiteres problem und deswegen
können wir gar nicht so tun als ob er
einfach da weiter machen wo wir und die
krise aufgehört haben mit
anführungszeichen sondern die wirtschaft
muss umsteuerung das ist genau etwas
woran wir dringend arbeiten müssen dass
wir dort behielten gegen wo wir neu
anfangen wo wir unterstützung geben für
unternehmen das für das richtige tun und
nicht das alter noch mal ich will noch
einmal auf den gedanken von der
grafischen ganz kurz und dann dann herr
blume auch sie wieder herab lösen das
würde bedeuten dass sie jetzt ganz
dringend von einem zweiten lockdown
flächendeckend abraten das darf auf
keinen fall passieren oder eben doch
unter bestimmten rechner wissen
voraussetzungen also
das wichtige ist wie sind unsere
kapazitäten ist unser gesundheitssystem
überfordert und da muss ich ja sagen das
ist völliger blödsinn was er erzählt
unser gesundheitssystem war in dem
ersten lockdown immer geradezu 20
prozent im durchschnitt ausgelastet wir
haben überhaupt kein problem da gehabt
in der versorgung wir wussten heilig wie
wir sie versorgen sollten das ist schon
richtig aber das ist natürlich auch eine
medizinische erfahrungssache die man da
irgendwo entwickelt als mediziner aber
unser gesundheitssystem ist auch heute
nicht wirklich belastet wir haben eben
in den tagesthemen gehört dass in
eppendorf 124 intensivbetten belegt
davon 4 durch corona wir haben im grunde
genommen ja heute tote irgendwo in der
größenordnung zwischen 40 und 50
menschen bei einer infektionsrate die
höhe ist als wir sie jemals in der
ersten welle gehabt haben
also das gesundheitssystem ist gut
vorbereitet wir haben ein sehr gutes
gesundheitssystem
wir müssen den leuten auch ein bisschen
vertrauen geben nicht so sehr
dieses panik und hysterie sondern so wie
manche trauen helfen ist das war ja ein
relativ harte abrechnung muss nicht mal
sagen also wir tun einiges dafür damit
wir diese kapazitäten haben aber die
these wenn ich sie richtig verstanden
habe lautet ja wir hätten mal gar nichts
machen sollen dann wäre das alles
irgendwie schon gut gelaufen sagt er
nicht schwedisches modell findet ja auch
nicht alle aber die nationen die das
auch medizinisch auf die leichte
schulter genommen haben haben am ende
auch eine härtere lockdown situation
bekommen als die die frühzeitig gesagt
haben achtung an der bahnsteigkante
hier ist eine ganz problematische
entwicklung natürlich sind wir derzeit
noch in sehr sehr wenig ausgelasteten
intensiv kapazitäten aber in hamburg
sind die zahlen innerhalb kurzer zeit
eben doch deutlich nach oben gegangen
und wir müssen ja ein bisschen voraus
denken wir können ja nicht sagen das war
ein super betrachtung und wenn es soweit
ist sagen wir jetzt haben wir aber
leider ein problem bekommen das denken
weil das war genau die frage herr blume
locker und war das stichwort auch von
herrn raffen locker und schließen sie
den aus diesem jahr einen drastischen
sagen also ich finde die republik ist
gut darin gefahren die politik das wirft
die virologen gehört haben und nicht auf
voodoo statistiken geschaut haben findet
immer sehr interessant was herr affichen
der republik präsentiert
aber ich kann hier nicht ernsthaft
erkennen was daraus für die politik aus
seinen überlegungen ableitbar sein soll
am ende würde das ja bedeuten dass ein
land wie china ein durch und durch
autoritäres regime es in seiner rechnung
am besten gemacht hat und ehrlich gesagt
das kann an der stelle nicht die schluss
ist das budo herrschen dann müssen sie
unbedingt noch mal antworten auf eine
blume voodoo sie sagen blödsinn was der
tschentscher erzählt jetzt springt herr
blume in die bresche und sagt das ist
wohl was sie rechnen
nein es ist nicht wo du es ist einfach
die haltung dass wir ruhe bewahren und
die gewisse demut durchfahren denn
nochmal politiker die hysterisch
reagieren
die brauchen wir nun wirklich nicht
sondern wir müssen mit gewisser
zuversicht da auch durch rudern wir
haben ein sehr gutes gesundheitssystem
das gesundheitssystem kann uns eine
menge an wirklichen schweren fällen auch
behandeln wir sind gut darauf
vorbereitet und deshalb ist das was wir
als kapitän am segelschiff inhalt machen
müssen ein vernünftiger kapitän wird das
segelschiff eben halt dann durch den
sturm bringen aber hysterie und panik
hat er an bord nicht besonders gerne
denn der entscheidende punkt ist doch
der folgende wir sehen dass unser
gesundheitssystem mehr und mehr
beansprucht wird alle zwei wochen
verdoppelt sich die inanspruchnahme der
intensiv medizin in deutschland von
corona und jetzt sind es im moment von
den fallzahlen absolut noch keine
besorgniserregenden werte aber wenn ich
das hochrechnen und eine unkontrollierte
entwicklung habe dann sehe ich dass wir
möglicherweise vor weihnachten schon in
eine situation kommen wo am ende dann
die situation in den krankenhäusern
kritisch wird weil dann eben nicht
genügend kapazitäten da sind und der
blick in unsere nachbarländer die umwelt
würde was version das muss man auch herr
festhält damit rechnen sie dass das
vorweihnacht wenn es ihren könnten ein
wenn wir als zweiter wenn die politik
gar nichts machen würde wenn wir es
einfach laufen lassen würden wenn wir
eine exponentielle entwicklung hätten
die politik noch erst wie woche und
woche verdoppelt sich die sache naja er
sagt wir sollen nicht mehr machen
wir sind doch jetzt am sure ob in diesen
tagen die weichen richtig gestellt sind
oder ob wir in deutschland noch mehr
machen müssen oder das haben wir letzte
woche ein vorletzter woche auch schon
gesagt das war immer die entscheidende
woche
man will ja auch nicht zu weit gehen
aber jetzt schon entscheiden das wird
dann auch mal schaffen dass wir die
kurve wieder abflachen plettenberg hat
in der ersten welle jeder davon
gesprochen jetzt sehen wir dass die
zahlen durch die decke gehen und zahlen
die durch die decke gehen landen immer
früher oder später auch im krankenhaus
und nochmal wir brauchen doch nur zu
unseren nachbarn schauen ich verstehe
nicht warum wir jetzt hier so voller
selbstzweifel sind was die strategie
angeht sind wir wollen wir wollen wissen
wo wir hin laufen ich habe gesagt ich
möchte keine verhältnisse nicht
mächtigen oder irgendwen niederländer
ist es waren die intensivmediziner die
im märz auch am uke gesagt haben wo wir
brauchen weitest gehende maßnahmen die
waren die sind oder hoch last vor diesem
problem sozusagen gestanden und haben
gefordert von der politik dass wir weit
gehende maßnahmen machen
ich habe aus meiner und unserer partner
park gehört dass dort wieder
feldlazarette jetzt aufgebaut werden das
ist jetzt keine theoretische respektive
das ist die eine das ist keine
theoretische perspektive sondern in die
feldlazarette in deutschland jedenfalls
ist es die situation in prag und das was
ich aus den europäischen nachbarländern
hören wir wollen ja dieses szenario grad
vermeiden deswegen sagen wir ja wir
müssen trotz dieser sehr hohen
kapazitäten genau auf diesen effekt
achten und ich glaube das hat sich
bewährt in der ersten phase obwohl ich
natürlich unserem skeptiker recht gebe
dass wir keine zweite lockdown situation
wie im frühjahr herbei führen werden wir
haben ja viele erkenntnisse was wirklich
etwas bringt und was wir vielleicht aus
mehreren schritten
das ist noch mal so es gibt viele namen
die haben wir einfach im frühjahr
getroffen auf auf dringende empfehlung
der virologen und der wissenschaftler
war noch zu wenig bekannt war zum
beispiel haben wir ja angenommen dass
die kleinsten kinder also kindergärten
geschlossen werden müssen spielplätze
nicht benutzt werden sollten
nein das ist etwas was ich nicht
bestätigt hat was mittlerweile erkannt
wurde das heißt das schließe das ist ja
was ganz wichtig ist erwarten hier
moment millionen deutsche mit ihren
kindern darauf zu hause mit sicherheit
zu haben okay das passiert in den
nächsten wochen in schulen und kitas
also sie würden für hamburg sprechen ja
für hamburg für hamburg würden sie sagen
geht das auf keinen fall
nein das ist jedenfalls etwas was wir
jetzt wissen dass das nicht so
empfindlich ist wie wie andere bereiche
und wir haben wie gesagt die spielplätze
unter freiem himmel geschlossen und
irgend haben wir festgelegt da gab es
keine das passiert nicht noch mal
das ist jedenfalls nicht das was jetzt
was jetzt bevorsteht als nächster
schritt sondern wir würden wenn wir ein
weiterer schritte benötigen würden wir
in den bereichen beginnen wo wir auch
wissen dass dort infektionsrisiken
liegen desto wilder ich kapiere sich
wiederholt sich nun der märz oder ist
das ein was die situation im märz wird
das sich so nicht wiederholen weil wir
neue erkenntnisse haben und wissen dass
bestimmte dinge einfach gar nicht wirken
und sie müssen nicht immer härtere
maßnahmen in einem bereich ergreifen da
keine auswirkung auf das würde ja sterns
viel sicherheit und ich glaube auch ganz
viel von der kritik nehmen wenn man das
aussprechen würde wenn sie jetzt heute
sagen würden auch sie aber ich bin kein
hellseher werden wir nicht mehr dicht da
geht es dann noch ein einsehen und unser
keine glaskugel noch mal darum geht es
ab sommer ist noch weit älter sagt dass
man erkennen muss das missverständnis
ist dass bei dieser corona pandemie
die politik oder die regierungen den
takt vorgeben das virus gibt den takt
vor und wir erleben jetzt eine zweite
welle die dann wird sich viel stärker
geworden ist in allen europäischen
ländern übrigens auch in den vereinigten
staaten als die erste welle wir
reagieren jetzt anders wir sind besser
vorbereitet als auf eine erste welle
aber ultimativ wissen was hilft um diese
kurve auch jetzt wieder abzuflachen
haben wir noch nicht gesehen und
deswegen kommt es jetzt darauf an dass
wir in diesen tagen in diesen zwei
wochen geht es für uns wirklich alles
tun dass jeder auch selbst den beitrag
leistet dass wir jetzt diese trendwende
hin bekommen aber noch mal ganz kurz und
dann können wir das abschließen weil sie
sagen wir sind jetzt schlauer geworden
wir haben mehr gelernt manche maßnahmen
sind nicht mehr nötig also zum beispiel
sie haben das beispiel mit dem spiel es
ist einfach so blumen müssen doch ein
nein es gibt doch eine prioritätenliste
man fängt doch da an wo die dinge lothar
zettler das machen wir diese zahl wenn
aber ich will doch jetzt kann der worst
case szenarien auf den tisch packen dann
wird mir wieder vorgeworfen das ist
alles ohne space den für menschen sei es
so schlimm wie sehr ist so dass nicht
mehr werden wir sehr bald eine impfung
bekommen dass wir jetzt die nächsten
wochen so diszipliniert sind dass wir in
einen niveau kommen es geht mir gar
nicht um die zahl wir können sicher eine
bestimmte ausmaß an infektionen ertragen
weil wir ja dieses leistungsfähige
gesundheitswesen haben
aber es darf nicht immer exponentiell
weiter nach oben geht dann überfordert
ist uns irgendwann deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir in einer stabilen eine
platte phase kommen sie können den
lockdown noch abwenden das ist dass ich
bin kein hellseher aber es hängt jetzt
wirklich davon ab was 80 millionen
menschen in deutschland wie
diszipliniert wir vorangehen und wie
viel verständnis und wie viel
verantwortungsbewusstsein auch von uns
allen weil ihr parteikollege lauterbach
sagt hellseherischen lockdown ist wohl
nicht mehr abwendbar wie sehen sie das
herr blume ist ja noch abwenden
es liegt jetzt an uns oder laufen wir da
direkt rein egal wie wir uns wahrlich
auf die natürlich liegt es an uns wie
gut deutschland diese zweite
bewährungsprobe besteht und im gegensatz
zur ersten welle haben wir jetzt ganz
klare prioritäten gesetzt wir haben den
gesundheitsschutz und daneben sollen
schulen kitas unter allen umständen
offen bleiben im regelbetrieb soweit das
möglich ist und wir wollen die
wirtschaft am laufen halten das sind die
drei essentiellen dinge und alles andere
es dann tatsächlich nachrangig dann muss
man halt mal verzichten auf
und dann muss man halt mal auf kontakte
im moment sich beschränken auf einige
wenige weil jeder dann wissen muss er
leistet damit nicht nur für sich etwas
gutes sondern für alle anderen auch und
wenn wir all das nicht machen dann
laufen wir aber rein in locktow so wie
es aussieht
die zahlen hängen und möchte sich artig
sich ja ein stück weit muss man auch
ertragen dass die zukunft davon abhängt
wie wir uns verhalten und die sicherste
möglichkeit die zukunft vorherzusehen
ist in so hat es willy brandt gesagt sie
zu gestalten die zukunft also wir haben
jetzt dinge in der hand wir haben diese
schnelltests wir müssen sie klug
einsetzen einen richtigen stellen aber
wir kommen nicht umhin an das
verantwortungsgefühl aller zu
appellieren weil es ja anders ist als
beste rezept gegen lok tor
ja weil das ist ja anders als in anderen
krisen wo jemand sagt der das risiko
nimmt und für sich selbst eine gefahr
hin geht auch zu schaden kommt
diejenigen die diese krise nicht ernst
nehmen gefährden alle anderen mit und
deswegen ist es auch so schwierig in der
in der politik und in der in der justiz
das maß zu finden die balance zu halten
nicht zu überziehen aber auf der anderen
seite auch frühzeitig die maßnahmen zu
ergreifen
denn man kann diese entwicklung auch
hier hinterher laufen und wir sehen ist
ja was in frankreich was in spanien
madrid ist abgeregelt ausgangssperre in
paris das sind ja wenn man so will keine
maßnahmen die die wir uns für
deutschland wünschen und deswegen sind
wir jetzt sehr aktiv und überlegen
reicht es aus was wir haben
oder brauchen wir weitere maßnahmen
einfach wenn eine stabilere lage zu
maßnahmen die bei ihnen in bayern schon
ergriffen wurden in einigen regionen
nämlich zum beispiel im landkreis
berchtesgaden da schon mal kurz hin
christina eltern in bad reichenhall im
landkreis berchtesgadener land ist
alleinerziehende mutter von zwei tätern
berufstätig und seit rund einer woche
erneut im corona lockdown sie dann hab
ich bei mir geschafft zu halbwegs die
arbeit hinter mir einkaufen gewesen
kinder bei den hausaufgaben geholfen
wäsche gewaschen haushalt gemacht und
dann sind hinzugekommen die kinder
nachher noch ein bisschen kern sie ernst
machen und dann muss ich morgen schon
wieder arbeiten und die fehler die
kinder rein lassen aber so ist man in
[Musik]
ihrem videotagebuch hält die mutter fest
wie ihr leben im zweiten lok dann
aussieht
ansonsten ist es sehr schwer überall wo
man hingehen in die stadt oder selbst
aufarbeiten menschen auf 1 zu und alles
in frustriert deprimiert und über die
situation komplett unzufrieden und
fassungslos wie konnte es soweit kommen
wer ist schuld fragen deren antworten
offenbar unterschiedlich ausfallen
können
das ist gerade alles läuft ich habe
jetzt auch davon gehört dass viele jetzt
in petitionen unterschrieben haben
dagegen vorgehen die gastronomen also
mittlerweile wird wirklich sehr
ungemütlich und das macht mir echt angst
[Musik]
der landkreis will mit den maßnahmen das
infektionsgeschehen im griff behalten
laut landrat sollen schulen und kitas
nach den ferien am 9 november wieder
öffnen wenn die infektionszahlen das bis
dahin hergeben und uns zugeschaltet uns
zugeschaltet ist jetzt christina hielten
im landkreis berchtesgaden schönen guten
abend die kinder laufen hoffentlich
sprechens hause
sie haben eine sehr anstrengende woche
hinter sich das weiß ich aus vielen
gesprächen wie lang schaffen sie das
noch in diesem zweiten lockdown nachdem
sie hofften dass das nicht noch mal
wiederkommt
selten ist die leitung gerade
zusammengebrochen da frag ich genau sie
das herr blume csu generalsekretär was
glauben sie wie lange die leute das
nicht nur in dem landkreis sondern
dieses hin und her immer wieder schließt
ist die angst das könnte genauso kommen
wie merz wie lange die das mitmachen
machen die das noch bis zum impfstoff
bis zum frühjahr oder was auch immer mit
das ist natürlich eine harte prüfung und
deswegen macht es sich ja auch niemand
leicht auch gerade in diesem fall vor
ort nicht mit dem verhängen dieser
maßnahmen nur wenn wir sehen dass wir
eine inzidenz haben die weit jenseits
des dunkelroten bereich ist heute
aktuell bei 250 das kommt natürlich auch
nicht von ungefähr in der ecke gerade in
österreich ein extremes
infektionsgeschehen in österreich hat
dort ganze orte abgeriegelt dass er
nicht das was wir gemacht haben also es
wird jetzt immer von lockdown geredet
faktisch haben die menschen dort
natürlich alle bewegungsfreiheit
die geschäfte sind offen die
dienstleistungen hinzu die
dienstleistung ist offen die schulen und
die kitas sind geschlossen worden
allerdings gibt es eine notbetreuung
aber die gilt natürlich dann auch nur
für ausgewählte berufsgruppen also man
kann es ganz kurz sagen es ist eine 1 1
der versuch eine lage wieder in den
griff zu bekommen
die drohte tatsächlich zu explodieren
das kann nur eine temporäre maßnahme
sein und wenn du das alles wirkt dann
wird danach logischerweise dann auch
wieder das gelten was sonst nach der ko
ohne ampel in deutschland gilt das ist
eine ausnahmesituation von denen viel
von der viele dachten eben das bleibt
eine ausnahme situation jetzt kommt die
eben ja im winter wieder zurück oder im
herbst wieder zurück was kaum sie frau
göring-eckardt wie lange da die geduld
vieler deutscher ist also wie und nicht
nur geduldet sondern auch schlichtweg
die fähigkeit im alltag das noch mal zu
organisieren noch mal die kraft zu haben
den alltag völlig umzuorganisieren mit
kindern usw
ich habe das muss eine derzeit allen
dingen sein dass die kitas und dass die
schulen nicht so gemacht werden und das
klar ist dass wir vorbereitet sein
müssen eigentlich schon hätten sein
müssen nicht erst jetzt dann so halt
damit anfangen dass die schulen da sind
dass man im zweifelsfall oben steigen
kann auch digital
recht und das ziel voraussetzung in den
schulen geschaffen sind da muss man ja
ganz ehrlich wir haben nicht über
schulden unter 60 gelüftet werden frage
ob man durch filter oder raumluft beide
die auch immer man die dinger bezeichnen
will angeschafft werden können die wird
im grunde genommen auch seit früher
diskutiert es passiert aber nicht und da
rede ich noch gar nicht darüber dass man
vielleicht bundeseinheitlich als
pandemie wirtschaft daran denkt dass so
was passiert wir erleben ganz einfach
vor ort dass das nicht geschieht das
macht die leute wahnsinnig wenn wir uns
anschauen dass wir diese untersuchung
gesehen haben beim württemberg war das
erste bundes einfach so eine studie
gemacht hat dass die infektionen am
allerwenigsten bei kindern insbesondere
speck eingehen dann passieren dann wäre
für mich dass die schulen auf also wenn
die frau an die arbeit gehen kann
dann können auch die kinder in die
schule gehen dann muss man so machen
dass die gruppen geteilt und so weiter
ich würde es gar kein trotzdem anders
geregelt oder warum wurde es trotzdem
anders gehandhabt in berchtesgaden der
blume warum hat man denen ich die
sicherheit gegeben zu sagen können
wenigstens weiter zur schule gehen das
wurde dort nach ärztlicher einschätzung
getroffen da gab es jetzt keine vorgabe
von woanders her
wir hatten oder wir haben in
berchtesgaden ein sehr diffuses
infektionsgeschehen wo du nicht mehr
genau weiß wer sich angesteckt hat
und das ist ja das wesen eines locker
und so da auch einer gewissen abstufung
dass du dann erst mal versucht alles
runter zu fahren um insgesamt das
infektionsgeschehen wieder in den griff
zu bekommen
ansonsten gilt die gruppe tätig von auch
gesagt habe schulen kitas müssen unter
allen umständen so lange wie möglich
offen bleiben das ist ja die hauptlast
frau leutheusser schnarrenberger ich
glaube das klang ja jetzt auch an der
runde schon durch wenn man diese
sicherheit vielen familien geben würde
dann wäre schon viel gewonnen mit
schulen und kitas also ich glaub das ist
das ganz entscheidende
das auch in orten wo wir ein hohes auch
ein dynamisches infektions gesehen haben
mit vielfältigen ursachen wird doch auch
da die wissenschaft beherzigen die
gerade sagt in kitas und schulen haben
wir nicht den starken infektionsherd es
gibt inzwischen konzepte im zweifel
müssen die noch mal verbessert werden
aber auch wenn ein solch angespanntes
infektionsgeschehen ist dann muss doch
gelten was jetzt die politik immer sagt
kitas und schulen werden nicht
geschlossen
denn das ist wirklich belastend auch
dazu haben wir jetzt ja studien und
untersuchungen was das mit kindern macht
mit kleinen kindern aber auch mit
grundschülern was das für die für eine
belastung ist wenn sie abgeschnitten
sind von ihren freunden von ihrem umfeld
und dass der digitale unterricht auch
noch nicht so funktioniert wie man sich
idealerweise vorstellt gerade in
berchtesgaden hat ja der landrat auch
orte genannt wo eben auch das mit wlan
nicht richtig funktioniert dann glaube
ich muss dass die absolute priorität
sein und ich möchte das was er gerade
nochmal arbeitslosen gesagt hat man muss
auch mit ein bisschen zuversicht man
kommt da raus und man wendet die
konzepte an die es gibt und dann ist es
eben nicht lockdown jetzt ist es einer
aber man muss da wirklich die priorität
setzen und alles tun dass das in kitas
und schulen nicht der fall ist und das
ist aller mühen wert und ich glaube dann
sind da auch viele viele menschen die
sagen ja wir gehen damit denn natürlich
müssen wir sie erreichen
und natürlich erreichen wir sie nicht
nur immer mit erhobenem zeigefinger
sondern wirklich mit argumenten mit
appel aber auch noch sehr viel stärker
daran dass wir sagen wir nehmen euch mit
ja wir verstehen eure nöte und von
leutheusser schnarrenberger ganz ganz
notwendig haben über schulen und kitas
gesprochen über ganz ganz viele
alltagsfragen alltags nöte eine
anstehende alltags frage ist wie findet
eigentlich weihnachten statt kanäle mit
meiner familie zumindest im größeren
kreis kann ich mit der feiern kann ich
mit der nicht feiern jetzt schon klar
wird dass das einsamste traurige
weihnachten in unsere ich hoffe das
natürlich nicht wir haben ja schon die
bei ostern diese sehr schwierige zeit
gehabt in der wir eigentlich ein
osterfest lieber gefeiert hätten
so wie wir es kennen und ich hoffe dass
wir weihnachten eine andere lager haben
wir haben unsere ganzen maßnahmen in
hamburg bis ende november jetzt zunächst
einmal begrenzt und gesagt wir werden
uns dass die nächsten wochen angucken
wir hatten noch im ersten block dort
übrigens immer eine notbetreuung für
kitas und auch schülerinnen und schüler
auch diese sicherheit hatten wir im
ersten akt
wenn es familiäre situationen gibt
eltern zur arbeit müssen die
kinderbetreuung die sichergestellt ist
gab es auch in hamburg eine eine
notbetreuung ohne dass wir
infektionsfälle hatten dh das ist etwas
was wirklich auch jetzt erfahrung ist
und das werden wir in situationen man
wartet ja mit der planung von
weihnachten halt nicht bis zum 23 jahren
geplant gericht kann man einladen
die ganze politische seien zwar nach
weihnachten sind wir durch und dann
kommt das alles noch viel schlimmer wir
müssen jetzt schon uns auf diese zeit
konzentrieren das ist wirklich eine zeit
in der es nichts zu feiern gibt und in
der wir versuchen müssen jetzt die
infektionszahlen würden sie jetzt raten
schon mal einzuladen oder auch könnte
gerade das einmal ich würde jetzt erst
einmal raten dass wir das noch einige
wochen ertragen und dass wir jetzt alles
daran setzen dass diese situation
eintritt die wir uns wünschen dass eine
entspannung gibt und dass wir vielleicht
auch maßnahmen über die
weihnachtsfeiertage machen können die
etwas stärker einer anderen bereich
zurück bringen und dann vielleicht
ermöglichen dass wir einigermaßen dass
das weihnachtsfest feiern können aber es
bleibt bei dieser erkenntnis dass gerade
familien feiern ja dadurch
gekennzeichnet ist dass die ältere
generation mit der jüngeren
zusammenkommt und da sind wir wieder in
diesem dilemma dieses virus das ist ja
kein problem der regierung oder der
verordnung dieses virus hat diese
eigenschaft dass es die ältere
generation so gefährdet und alle anderen
aber die übertragung machen können also
weihnachten noch nicht organisieren rät
tschentscher lieber noch nicht
vorsichtig sein lieber noch niemanden
einladen der blume
wir haben es selbst in der hand da
entscheiden jetzt die nächsten zwei drei
wochen darüber und eines sagen sind
immer wieder dass das tut mir leid aber
ich habe das natürlich gar nicht in der
hand wir als gesellschaft haben das er
in der hand aber wir haben wir uns an
die regeln halte jedoch natürlich gar
nicht in der hand jeder einzelne hat es
in der hand also je mehr wir uns jetzt
an strengen disziplin zu halten mit
unseren kontakten desto eher ist das
möglich und was anderes wir haben nur
allzu oft in den vergangenen jahren wird
lag dass die weihnachtszeit die
vorweihnachtszeit die adventszeit so
hektisch ist und so viel trubel und
sowie zusammenkunft vielleicht wird es
diesmal auch in der vorweihnachtszeit
eine adventszeit mal wieder so was wie
eine starke zeit geben ich will da nicht
romantisch oder sehnsüchtig werden aber
ich glaube ganz unlauter wenn sie das
sagen sie haben es selbst in der hand
hat sind was nämlich am ende selber
schuld wenn wir weiter
dann nicht mehr mit der familie feiern
wir aber das muss ich doch mal gäste
kommen müssten eine weihnachtliche
stimmung auch im öffentlichen raum wir
haben jetzt zwei spieler rassistischen
rainer schelkle wenn das weihnachtsfest
nicht im größeren kreis der familie
stattfindet sie sagen wir haben selbst
in der hand jetzt jetzt passiert sie
zahlen gehen weiter hoch da bin ich
selbst schon ohne ist eine plage die
über uns gekommen ist denn da trägt
jetzt zunächst mal keiner verantwortung
aber wie wir als freiheitliche
gesellschaft damit umgehen das haben wir
natürlich schon ein gutes stück selbst
in der hand hat und je mehr wir uns
daran halten und etwas rücksichtnahme
walten das ist eine frage von
solidarität mit seiner mitmenschen
ich bin mit leider einstimmung auf
weihnachten die richtige für das
vielleicht darf ich aber ich hab in
unserer bischöfe in hamburg auch über
diese frage schon gesprochen auch die
kirchen überlegen jetzt jedenfalls
unsere bischöfe ob man etwas macht was
ein besonderes weihnachtsfest ist ein
gottesdienst unter freiem himmel zum
beispiel sowas ist durchaus möglich und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt ein bisschen
versuchen uns über diese schwierige
monate jetzt ja hinweg zu bewegen ohne
dass wir in depressionen verfallen und
und die die die zuversicht auch
verlieren weil wir werden eine
weihnachtliche stimmung herstellen
können wir werden vielleicht nicht die
klassischen weihnachtsmarkt mit glühwein
organisieren aber sich doch anderem das
geringste ja aber ist das familienfest
tschentscher und dann wollen wir
vielleicht damit die runde nachdem wir
schon weit über die zeit sind einmal
beschließen
frau göring-eckardt noch einmal fragen
darf mir der staat in ihren augen
überhaupt verbieten ob ich tante und
onkel zu weihnachten noch einladen oder
nicht
in der stadt kann ich nur sagen was für
regeln gelten und was er empfiehlt in
solchen fällen und es wird sicherlich
nicht die polizei bei 320 wenn sie zwei
leute ein daten vor der tür steht aber
aber es muss ganz klar sein wir sollten
uns jetzt darauf vorbereiten dass
schwierige zeiten sein können und das
eine ist anders als gestern übrigens
werden gottesdienste stattfinden und die
werden wahrscheinlich anders sein
scheint hat das gesagt die hälfte der
deutschen ungefähr sind christinnen und
christen und für die ist weihnachten
natürlich damit verbunden dass der
gottesdienst ist manchmal wir sehen
manchmal geht es nicht immer aber erst
mal gehört das dazu
und dann fragen sie kann ich tante und
onkel rheinanlagen das wissen wir gar
nicht in welche bis zu welchem
verwandtschaftsgrad sicherlich wird es
nicht so sein dass alle leute irgendwie
durch die gegend fahren und weil ich zu
seine wohnung drei tage gebucht und so
weiter wie alle jahre und deswegen
gehört für mich auch dazu dass wir jetzt
überlegen die geht das irgendwie sorgen
wir dafür dass diejenigen die anleihen
sind nicht alleine bleiben müssen und
das ist finde ich auch eine
gesellschaftliche aufgabe also
vielleicht wird es dann eben nicht so
sein dass man weiß was ich unbedingt
nach berchtesgaden pferd und denkmal
besucht sondern vielleicht ist es jemand
in berchtesgaden der sagt ich mache das
für dich und in berlin bin etwas anderes
statt wo die nachbarin eingeladen wird
ich glaube das ist so eine frage von
zusammenhalt die wir dieses mal
möglicherweise auf andere art und weise
ausprobieren müssen und vielleicht
helfen da die kirchgemeinde vielleicht
helfen da die lokalen aktionen in alle
möglichen leute dabei darauf sollten wir
uns einstellen nicht ganz normales
weihnachten aber dass weihnachten wird
und das ist nicht machen wir ostern dass
wir alle einfach nur ein zuhause bleiben
das ist ziemlich klar jetzt schon
verstehe ihr letztes wort bitte kurz vor
leutheusser schnarrenberg auch an sie
noch mal die frage private feiern die
gilden hier zum beispiel in berlin jetzt
nur bis 10 in vielen anderen orten auch
das heißt eben dass tante und onkel oft
oben rausfahren die sind dann nicht mehr
dabei wenn man drei kinder hat dazu noch
großvater großmutter von beiden seiten
und so weiter dann ist man sehr schnell
bei 10 darf mir der status überhaupt
sagen wer an der familien tafel sitzt
dann weihnachten
also weihnachten ist ja wirklich ein
fest auch gerade der familie und deshalb
muss alles ermöglicht werden dass sich
da auch familie rede jetzt nicht von
großfamilien mit 500 mitgliedern von
clans sondern mit familie kann familie
sich natürlich treffen kann
ich finde es richtig wie das in
nordrhein westfalen ist das da
empfehlungen gegeben werden aber nicht
regelungen vorgegeben werden
verbindliche art weil sonst wirklich es
sein kann dass weihnachten an der tür
geklingelt wird dann steht da nicht der
weihnachtsmann sondern der polizist oder
uniformierte und das ist genau das was
man das wird nicht so sein aber das ist
ja interessant klingelt nicht der
weihnachtsmann klingelt ja nicht mehr
kommt der durch den kamin aber kommt
nicht der weihnachtsmann sondern das
ordnungsamt nein das ist das hat es auch
in der ersten phase nicht gegeben
aber natürlich wenn er doch das hat
schon hinein also wie in hamburg haben
natürlich finde es hinweise gibt dass
der sonate gemacht wird in den nachbarn
dann klopft man natürlich fasst es hier
denn passiert so geht das ja nicht aber
dass wir jetzt sozusagen mal
stichprobenartig in die in die
privatsphäre unserer bürgerinnen und
bürger einschreiten das ist das ist
keine wie was ist seither immer das
bitte nicht machen würde ich ihm auch
ein zu großer wunsch vieler die sagen
ich besuche dieses jahr meine eltern
vielleicht nicht wie viel sie nicht
gefährden das ist ja auch etwas wird das
hat ja einen hintergrund wir machen auch
diese regeln und diese empfehlung nicht
um zu studieren sondern es ist doch eine
eine dringende empfehlung damit wir
gerade die für die wir ja dieses fest
feiern wollen nicht in gefahr bringen
und deswegen glaube ich ist das schon
ist das schon eine schwierige lage
aber ich glaube da sollten wir an der
politik uns jetzt nicht gegenseitig die
schuld geben wer mehr dafür
verantwortlich ist dass es jetzt nicht
feierlich wird wir sollten daran
arbeiten und das hinzubekommen
und es gibt diesen eingriff in die
familie nicht in die familien tafel
es gibt jedenfalls keine kontrollen in
diesem sinne wir haben auch eine eine
rechts eine rechtsprechung die dem
familie die mir die familien sind
familiären zusammenhang einen hohen
stellenwert einräumt deswegen sagen wir
zum beispiel in hamburg zehn personen
zwei haushalte ausnahme sind und dann
kommen eben diese familienmitglieder
ersten grades und
pflege scharf auf ein ja aber das ist
der rechtsstaat dass wir sagen diese
familie ist geschützt und deswegen gibt
es da auch keine keine kontrollen im
sinne von wir gehen da jetzt mal durch
die wohnzimmer
auch in bayern nicht keine kontrollen im
weihnachts wohnzimmer noch mal ich finde
wir sollten bei diesen themen seriös
bleiben chor oder ist für jeden von uns
eine solche prüfung ist so existenziell
für viele frau göring eckardt als vorhin
angesprochen und realistisch also das
hätte ich jetzt nicht als unseriös
abgetan eine frage ob das ordnungsamt
daneben auch an weihnachten diese zehn
erregend ist will doch kein noch mal es
gibt es immer die familien nicht lässig
wohnzimmer und deswegen sogar die
vermutung der bürger soll sich soll dem
staat irgendwie gefallen
es gibt all diese regel nur weil corona
so gefährlich ist weil es sich an viele
dinge einfach nicht hält und deswegen
müssen wir alles versuchen corona
einzudämmen nicht die weiße fahne hissen
und nicht gerade dann am weihnachtsfest
an der weihnachtstag für den stein dafür
zu legen dass wir dann ins neue jahr
sehr beschwert starten das kann er
wirklich keiner wollen dann ziehen wir
einmal ein strich drunter danke dass sie
so lange mit diskutiert haben das
verspannt frau göring-eckardt frau
leutheusser schnarrenberger herzlichen
dank dafür peter tschentscher bei uns im
studio und markus blume ebenso danke
fürs kommen nach berlin
wir wollen ganz zum schluss der sendung
uns noch einem gast widmen der sich
gerade mit corona angesteckt hat und
dadurch noch mal in einer ganz
besonderen persönlichen lage ist und das
ist der frühere profi boxer vitali
klitschko der mir nun zugeschaltet ist
schönen guten abend herr klitschko so
gute nahrung
sie sind jetzt mittlerweile selbst ein
corona erkrankt deswegen die wichtigste
frage natürlich wie geht es ihnen
wir sind schon gespannt
wegen meiner arbeit weil ich sehr viele
menschen finden die us behörden gesuchte
krankenhäuser sogar ein doktor nachbarn
her eben immer alles kontrollieren
verbreiten büro alle fälle
die wissen nicht wie weit wird von dem
image sich entwickeln und deswegen hatte
sie viele kontakte und weg war
überrascht seit 1 jahr aber jemand
negativ getestet gerster ist positiv und
habe ich lerne hoffen weil ich habe ja
keine sektoren
ich fühle mich richtig gut so ich habe
kein fieber halsschmerzen keine
kopfschmerzen
ich fühle mich voll gesund gern zoom das
heißen sie hoffen noch so ein bisschen
darauf dass der test vielleicht sogar
falsch war ja schon mal passiert
ziemlich ich habe haben mir schon
beispiele wo eine ferien sogar mein von
quelle getestet und danach die zweite
das hat negative gezeigt und deswegen
morgen mache ich nächste und vielleicht
das war eine belle
wir drücken auf jeden fall die daumen
wenn der test sich dann doch bestätigt
haben sie irgendeine idee wo sie sich in
den letzten tagen angesteckt haben
könnten
ich habe ideen wo ich kleinen
krankenhäuser zweimal in den sektoren
abteilung vorletzte woche wegen meiner
arbeit und habe ich hunderte von
pressestelle ich verfolge geben die
regeln mit maske was mich raus wegen der
infektion aber trotzdem ich kann nicht
genau sagen wenn man so topfit ist wie
sie wenn man leistungssportler
profisportler war hat man das gefühl mal
corona kann mir sowieso nichts anhaben
wissen sie was ich glaube nicht zu
betreiben
opa monate habe ich ein sportler besuch
das war 34 jahre alt und kräftig ein
athlet und paar tage später nach seinen
besuchern vorgekommen er ist nicht mehr
primär
deswegen nicht noch den nicht betreiben
das ist sehr beständig an sein schicksal
aber man muss immer aufpassen und
verfolgt und begeisterte in ich
wiederhole irgendwoher and eve ich würde
ohne bitte wollten sie die wir regeln
werde
das ist unsere gesundheit das relevant
das ist die wichtigste der klitschko
jetzt befinden sie sich gerade in
quarantäne corona krank beziehungsweise
corona positiv getestet hier in
deutschland hat es den
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
erwischt er ist mittlerweile ja auch mit
corona in quarantäne
wollen sie einen kurzen gruß schicken an
ihren leidensgenossen in berlin
ich liebe erste bleibe schnell gesund
und ja das ist und ab gehen sehr viele
entscheidende
[Musik]
das betrifft in medizin und ich weiß von
meiner in der eigenen erfahrung
mediziner in deutschland in eine serie
euro und deswegen denke ich mal der
erkrankung minister von volkswirten
keine haben
ich glaube weil er meine dauer kann ich
immer spielen aber diese gehabt deswegen
wenn wirklich bedauert das ist und wir
vitali drücken von hier aus berlin für
sie die daumen dass es bei symptomfrei
bleibt und sie bald wieder raus können
und vollständig gesund sind
möglicherweise ja sogar dass der test
fehlerhaft war und sie dann schon ganz
schnell wieder das haus verlassen können
in voller gesundheit sehr viele
informationen gegeben weil ich habe koch
institut eine eine sehr feine
instituten in die ganze welt und
deswegen noch den gast gedanken mit der
entfernung der theorien vor was bekommen
wird das steht uns sehr
deswegen liebe user durch st bleiben sie
bitte gesund und gingen sie bitte regeln
und danke vitali klitschko schönen abend
nach kiew danke herzlich und bessere
schlusswort kann es nicht geben das war
vitali klitschko mit bleiben sie gesund
und das war der bildstock die richtigen
fragen wir sind nächsten sonntag zurück
21.45 bis dahin
[Musik]